양자 정보와 계산 이해하기 강의에 다시 오신 걸 환영해요. 저는 John Watrous이고 IBM
Quantum의 교육 기술 책임자예요. 이번 강의는 시리즈의 15번째이고, 양자 오류
수정을 다루는 4번째 단원의 세 번째 강의예요. 지금까지 9 qubit Shore
코드, 7 qubit Steane 코드, 5 qubit 코드 등 몇 가지 양자 오류 수정 코드 예시를 살펴봤고, 이를
수학적 기반으로 설명하고 분석할 수 있게 해주는 안정자 형식도 다뤘어요. 이 외에도 많은 양자 오류 수정
코드를 설명하고 분석할 수 있어요. 방금 말씀드린 코드들은 분명히 흥미롭고 양자 오류 수정 탐구를
시작하기에 자연스러운 출발점이에요. 문제는 이 코드들이 아주 낮은 오류율만 허용할 수 있다는 거예요.
5개, 7개, 9개 중 1개의 qubit 오류를 수정하는 건 나쁘지 않지만, 우리가 추측하는 것처럼
대규모 양자 컴퓨팅을 실현하려면 그보다 훨씬 많은 오류를 허용할 수 있어야 할 거예요.
이번 강의에서는 좀 더 정교한 양자 오류 수정 코드 구성들을 처음으로 살펴볼 거예요. 지금까지 본 것들보다
훨씬 높은 오류율을 허용할 수 있고, 실제 양자 오류 수정의 유망한 후보로 여겨지는 코드들이에요.
실제 물리적 장치에서도요. 강의의 간략한 개요를 소개할게요. CSS 코드라는
양자 오류 수정 코드 클래스부터 시작할 거예요. 이 코드는 이를 처음 발견한 연구자들인 Robert Calderbank, Peter
Shor, Andrew Steane의 이름을 따서 지어졌어요. CSS 코드 구성을 통해 특정 고전
오류 수정 코드 쌍을 결합해 양자 오류 수정 코드를 만들 수 있어요. 그 과정에서
고전 선형 코드를 간단히 살펴보고, CSS 코드의 기본 속성들도 이야기할 거예요.
강의의 두 번째 파트는 토릭 코드라고 알려진 코드에 관한 거예요. 이건 근본적이고 정말
아름다운 양자 오류 수정 코드 예시로, 상대적으로 높은 오류율을 허용할 수 있어요. 실제로
토릭 코드는 단일 양자 오류 수정 코드 예시가 아니라 코드의 무한한 패밀리예요. 각각
2부터 시작하는 양의 정수에 대한 코드가 있어요. 강의의 마지막 파트에서는 다른 몇 가지
양자 코드 패밀리에 대해 간략히 이야기할 거예요. 토릭 코드와 밀접하게 연결된 surface 코드와
color 코드도 포함해서요. 사람들은 1940년대부터 고전 오류 수정 코드를 연구해왔어요.
이건 매력적이고 풍부한 주제예요. 선형 코드는 아마도 가장 단순한 유형의 고전 오류
수정 코드예요. 이 맥락에서 선형이라는 단어가 정확히 무엇을 의미하는지 잠깐 후에 설명할게요. 간단히
표현하면 이들은 고전적인 안정자 코드예요. 곧 CSS 코드가 기본적으로 고전 선형 코드 쌍을
결합해 양자 오류 수정 코드를 만드는 것임을 알게 될 거예요. 그 논의를 위해 고전
선형 코드에 대한 몇 가지 기본적인 것들을 이해해야 해요. 먼저 이 전체
논의에서 Σ를 이진 알파벳으로 사용할 거예요. 이제 고전 선형 코드라고 할 때, 길이 n의 이진 문자열 집합 C를 의미해요. 어떤
양의 정수 n에 대해서요. 단 하나의 기본 속성만 만족하면 돼요. u와 v가 C에 속하는 이진 문자열이면 문자열
u XOR v도 C에 속해야 한다는 거예요. 여기서 u XOR v는 u와 v의 비트별 배타적 OR을 의미해요.
이건 시리즈의 양자 알고리즘 파트인 5번째와 6번째 강의에서 여러 번 봤던 거예요. 이것이 고전
코드가 선형이라는 의미예요. 본질적으로 길이 n의 이진 문자열을 n차원 벡터로 생각하는 거예요.
각 항목은 0 또는 1이지만, 실수나 복소수 위의 일반적인 벡터 덧셈 대신
모듈로 2 덧셈을 사용해요. 이게 바로 XOR이에요. 그러니까
두 코드워드 u와 v, 즉 C에 속하는 이진 문자열이 있으면, u + v 모듈로 2, 다시 말해 u XOR
v도 코드워드여야 해요. 그리고 이 함의는 u가 v와 같더라도 참이어야 해요. 그 가능성을 배제할 수 없어요.
그리고 이는 모든 고전 선형 코드에는 반드시 전부 0인 문자열이 포함되어야 함을 의미해요. 왜냐하면
어떤 문자열과 그 자신의 비트별 XOR은 전부 0인 문자열이기 때문이에요. 예를 들어, 3비트
반복 코드는 고전 선형 코드예요. 특히 u에 대한 선택지가 두 가지, v에 대한 선택지가 두 가지 있어요.
가능한 쌍들을 살펴보면, 비트별 XOR을 취할 때 항상 코드워드가 나온다는 걸 쉽게 알 수 있어요.
또 다른 예시는 [7,4,3] 해밍 코드예요. 이건 가장 먼저 발견된 고전 오류
수정 코드 중 하나예요. 길이 7의 이진 문자열 16개로 구성돼요. 이 문자열들의 선택에는 아주 단순한 논리가 있지만
이 영상에서는 설명하지 않을 거예요. 이 문자열들이 뒤집혀 있는 경우도 있지만
지금은 중요한 점이, 이 문자열들 중 어느 두 개를 골라 XOR하면 코드 내의 다른 문자열을 얻는다는 거예요.
그러니까 선형 코드예요. [7,4,3]이라는 표기에서 단일 대괄호는 이전 강의에서 안정자 코드에 대해
말했던 이중 대괄호 표기와 유사한 의미예요. 하지만 여기서는 고전 선형
코드에 대한 거예요. 특히 코드워드는 7비트이고, 코드워드가 16개이므로 코드를 사용해 4비트를 인코딩할 수 있어요.
거리 3 코드이기도 해요. 즉, 한 코드워드에서 다른 코드워드를 얻으려면 최소 3비트를 뒤집어야 해요.
그리고 이는 최대 1비트 오류를 수정할 수 있음을 의미해요. 이것들은 단순한 예시들이에요.
[7,4,3] 해밍 코드 예시조차도 코드워드를 단순히 나열할 때는 다소 신비로워 보여요. 그러니 고전 선형 코드를
더 잘 설명할 방법이 필요해요. 자연스러운 방법이 두 가지 있어요. 하나는 고전
선형 코드를 코드를 생성하는 최소 코드워드 집합으로 설명하는 거예요. 이 코드워드들의 모든 가능한
부분집합을 XOR하면 전체 코드를 얻을 수 있어요. 이건 화면에 수학적 표현으로 나타나 있어요.
또 다른 방식으로는, 이 코드를 벡터 공간의 부분 공간으로 보는 거예요. 이 생성자 집합은
그 부분 공간의 기저예요. 산술이 모듈로 2로 이루어지는 벡터 공간임을 기억하세요. 생성자가 M개 있으면,
코드는 2의 M제곱개 원소를 갖게 돼요. 각 생성자는 코드의 원소 수를 두 배로 늘려요.
이진 알파벳 위의 고전 선형 코드는 항상 2의 거듭제곱 수의 문자열을 포함한다는 사실과
일치해요. 고전 선형 코드를 설명하는 두 번째 자연스러운 방법은 패리티 체크예요. 이는 코드의 문자열과 같은 길이를 가진 이진 문자열의
최소 목록인데, 코드의 문자열은 정확히 이 패리티 체크 문자열들 각각과의 이진 내적이 0인 것들이에요.
이진 내적은 단순히 일반적인
내적인데, 각 항목의 곱의 합을 모듈로 2로 계산하는 거예요.